hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
listen to the soothing sounds of music
this is a calm place relaxing no stress
here only Joy's thoughts nothing is
standing behind you nothing is lurking
in your closet nothing is watching you
from the corners and the shadows
nothing is stalking you you're safe
inside your home you're safe
they can't give you here they're not
already inside you're safe so let's
start with some scary games now that
we're nice and safe and comfortable
we're gonna start with a game called two
lines do okay I don't know what this
game is about to tender lines carefully
drawn two for life two for death I don't
like the implication rule willow where
am I I'm in a very dirty bathroom oh and
now I'm playing yep that is just about
the Crimea's bathtub I've ever seen it's
so stained with blood
it's marred the porcelain I kind of move
a little funny is that door made of so
uh what's going on here what's the
dealio what's the story what's it going
on these aren't doors oh wow oh my what
the hell is that
that doesn't seem normal okay Matheson
and Midwich okay block Street am I
supposed to remember these at all no
even the building was red everything
about that place was red this is
moderately unsettling love the music
though very very nice just gonna wander
through these empty streets hoping that
nothing's gonna happen well I don't know
how I got here oh these buildings are
more red is this a clue am I headed in
the right direction I'm assuming this
way this way I'm going up I'm going up
baby I'm going up hello
you the dude from Death Note oh I'm
thinking you might be able to navigate
these a little better than I am okay see
you around buddy
alright so that guy's no fun but maybe
he's lots of fun I don't know I never
really gave him a chance to say I ran
away a little too quick okay is he still
a stomping he's still a stomping this
way I'm gonna sue me and I should
probably keep moving
didn't know that I could pick up so much
zoom so is my objective just to run away
that all I'm doing going up find another
place I feel like I'm being herded but
playing right into its hands
Oh where do these go Oh what the hell
what the hell is with this place this is
so weird I don't know why the just the
architecture what the hell why I don't
know why the architecture is unsettling
to me but it is something just
inherently weird about it
just this idea that every rooftop is
connected by these red bridges where am
I going am I just going in a circle no
not quite I think I left that dude far
behind so I think I'm okay unless I just
went in a big circle well oh I hear him
okay hey bud oh yeah yeah I should keep
moving
yeah I should keep moving yeah he ain't
let enough cuz it's like the futility of
running away from death nothing could
ever stop it enough nothing could ever
slow it down it's this constant ticking
of time this slowly ticks down to the
end of your pitiful rope the candle of
your life being snuffed out in the end
just a tiny flame trying to stay alive
in a hurricane
that is life Yatta Yatta symbolism blah
blah blah what happened to my dick jokes
and ass jokes pontificating about the
inevitability of the bitter end that we
all meet called hard ground reaching up
to embrace us cans of dirt grabbing our
throats and clawing us underneath
nothing will ever stop and nothing it'll
ever slowed it way just keep marching on
hoping that through the future
generations that come after us we get
some sorta semblance of immortality but
we're all just spinning on a rock
floating in space cosmic forces beyond
our comprehension threatening dark snuff
out the candle that is our planet we are
such insignificant wisps of sparks of
life I'm ascending is weird oh my god
the hell is up
man whoever made this probably had a
field day with the model and oh my god I
hope they had a system that made it easy
Oh God said the street or the sky or a
Plaza or a choice
I don't know I'm already on this path I
don't think it matters I don't know I'm
kind of just having fun going through
these uh these little pathways here it's
a different experience but I'm all about
that you know sometimes horror games or
scary games could be very formulaic and
this is just like such a bizarrely new
idea that I'm super into it I don't know
why that dude is chasing me but frankly
I don't care it's it is awesome I love
this way blood Street if that's a blood
no block milk Street are you there about
dude Oh another Plaza
all right choices to be made I guess Oh
God choices to be made I might just be
going back the way I came for all I know
I guess I'll know if I run into the dude
what is going on what is it happen oh my
god am i looping back to places I've
been
how would I know how would I ever know
how can anybody know what is happenin
here okay I'm going somewhere I may just
be going back the way I came I don't
know where who what where oh hi I don't
know if you're closer far I'm losing my
mind
I'm losing my marbles god I had no idea
was it for this kind of an experience
does it ever end god it's like an SCP to
some bizarre world dimension third world
dimension I'm definitely looping oh I'm
100% looping I've got to be I don't know
exactly where I am but whoa what what no
way no way no no
oh no no no okay I've been here I have
been here I think I took that path
before unless I took this path and now
I'm just being dumb there has to be some
kind of path here the street names
aren't helping because oh whoa yeah yeah
up is uh ups good whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa oh my god okay
whoa I didn't mean it I'm sorry I
apologize whoo hi
oh well no there's no need why hey wait
a minute I deserve what what anyway oh
no oh no I don't deserve two lines Wow
oh this is the same person that made
nemesis never cease oh that was a great
experience I really liked that it was
way different but I liked it I really
did I like that a lot
that was cool that was really cool Matt
Reeves well done and I will keep my eyes
peeled for nemec's what the [ __ ]
okay this one's called one got in the
house turn around
where did the children go wait the evil
got me oh that's sad first these ago to
my family who's being haunted by cancer
oh okay downstairs hallway what left
door the darkness you can feel it wait
you died large closet okay so don't wait
what's buying those doors door number
one is there any way to survive this an
unfinished dish right wait what the evil
is gone you serve out Wow Wow I think
that's literally just a jump-scare game
what was eaten here Oh evil is gone
okay that's kinda that's kind of cool
it's different it's weird it reminds me
of like there was an era when there was
a lot of like point-and-click style
horror games like this like how what was
it called I have to look it up okay I'm
gonna get out of this real quick not bad
I like it kind of like a randomly
generated horror game um let's see cube
escape what's a cube escape have there
been like more or games I'm looking for
uh I forget what it's called it's like
Exorcist or something like that there's
a lot more horror games so I thought
there'd be on here maybe I should try
them out fear would hides in the mist
that sounds cool okay I don't know what
this is hide you know it's not even what
I was thinking about whoa it's not what
I was expecting
this is so weird this is not what I was
like prescribed to play this went on a
bit of a bender no one seems to be here
huh interesting
I need a jerrican for this it's getting
foggy ooh what the hell happened here I
don't know a lot of blood this PC
controls gas pumps I need to find weeds
getting real foggy outside so foggy I
got a can
okay do I go back out late your I've got
a can not a jerrycan knife okay
yeah nice can knife okay can knife okay
oh you can see me okay your bail out
louder than I probably oh god it's been
so much this is not what I was looking
for oh geez okay um it was like I feel
it was called um what was it called ex
mortis that was it ex mortis it's mortis
sad rules I played this one a long time
ago November 25th 2012 hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
let's play ex mortis expertise oh yeah
those dog pictures of his friends that
he photoshopped to be bloody highs a
blasphemer passed 2004 [ __ ] 2004 this
gives 16 years old Wow with a lump on
your head you can remember how you got
are you gonna man
and memories let's see if I remember
anything about this it's been a long
look at this flash ass flash [ __ ] look
at this delete tool magic eraser done
ass transparency you've got going on
here well I'm lost in the woods time to
go in this house of course God okay with
the pacing you know I I honestly truly I
love me a good point and click
there's something very disconcerting
about the style like it's just the style
is shockingly good sometimes just
another painting on the wall one two
three four five six easy
got it remembered in my brain old fans
like little descriptions dark hallways I
love that [ __ ] there's something about
the the lack of you know navigational
control that makes it like fun there's a
be a fresh kill
I really have just played this ah looks
like a symbol has been smeared on the
forehead and among other things that
have happened to that head hello ah good
knife oh oh oh guys guys play through it
goddamn it
all right screw it that's not what I was
doing anyway I just reminded of it if
you want to see export as I did it in
November 25th 2012 okay this is called
the ward if you can't read all right
let's do this
a very small percent of individuals
epileptic seizure seizure warning
everybody seizure
hey hey you're finally awake oh we are
all I remember is I was having a great
nap and then BAM Here I am I guess
well whatever let's get out of here
maybe things will start to make a bit
more sense okay am i like you were I'm
kind of a traveler
I've been a ton of places but this one
really take you hey you have eyes on the
back of your head you you literally have
eyes on the back of your head why you
you have eyes on the back oh you have
eyes on the top of your head first
things first let's get something to
watch on the TV then maybe see if you
can find me a pack of cigarettes all
right oh one last thing
grab me a bite to eat won't you sweet
cheeks
sweet cheeks maybe see if you can find
me a pack of cigarettes
[Music]
that's what I was gonna your salary is
that right I know that the real just
move me on the couch I'm gonna miss the
damn game Oh Oh go baby go baby go baby
go baby go hey kid do something right
for once and go that's my favorite take
back with Timmy Peterson Warriors play
extra he was the best bet for the
Aberdeen thing mr. Nye that's apparently
and I you know what kid you're all right
pick some time we can play cat pegs
bucko
oh I want to go back to X Marcus please
honey you need something to eat that's
right
anybody got anything to eat in here
anything they're not using you know
bring this back
yo yo yo k here you want this what okay
that's there for you uh you want
something to watch on the telly I got
the best thing get a baseball highlights
this work fun but beats watching grass
grow I guess
thanks a bunch okay all right well just
be on my way towards whoever the hell
this is hi ru you look different you
need you need help with that you need
there you go here you go I got you
I'm sorry I didn't I don't know I have
no word there is no commentary to be
made about this suite thanks buddy
you're the best friend a fella could ask
call me sweet cheeks
that's what I love and that's what I
know hi
goodbye forget what the [ __ ] did I just
say did I see a pair of lips on a
floating spire of flesh very penis like
is that what I saw yeah good to see
you've finally decided to get out and if
you don't like it we'll cook it yourself
Oh
[Laughter]
thank you sweetheart he appreciates for
noon time with you like this could you
give me a hand and round up the others
for supper
oh this is so unsettling so so
unsettling unbelievably unsettling and I
don't know why is it the smooth jazz
that's yeah you wanted in the dead oh
well you're still dead
hey mom if that's what I call you that I
can't find you found Shane here oh well
it was only a matter of time you guys
ain't so bad landing feeling well what
can I say
I'm a green
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay well that was probably to seizure
inducing an even show all when we're
done what I feel thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed this uh I know I did
thank you if you want to see more scary
games links in the description if you
want to play these for yourself maybe
that game would have a different ending
if you didn't accidentally kill the
other guy more scare games suggested
videos description Hey
ring that bell ring ring ring a ling a
ding that bowed that dinner bells
ringing you better get to the table or
mom's gonna be upset so thanks and as
always I will see you
[Music]